what's the T today the T is green
smoothie juice spinach celery apple
apple juice chia seeds and some other
things too banana let's play another
game
toxic banana party welcome back just as
I say banana I feel like I the banana
party so my goal if you're just joining
I want to get 2600 before I get to
20,000 I'm on pace kind of yeah another
d4 game I'll just play d5 I'll stick
with my main repertory Bishop f4 let's
play each v e5 so this is the whole
point of HIV v just wins the piece it's
so funny g5 h for such a funny trap I
tried doing this other day and I mouse
slipped be six instead of e5 I was
tragic this is so great I'm just winning
a bishop its h5 trap refutation to the
London and the position is gonna be very
pleasant like pawn structure a messed up
have extra extra dark-squared bishop
mighty for may be coming so I'll play
this move first preventing my d4 and may
be preparing g4 okay black wants our
white wants to to do things on the D
file so let's play g4 first Jason I away
from defending the pond I could consider
taking I'll just play this move in 97 96
just natural development ie 5 should
follow the Knights kind of just stuck
and someday I'll have a queen-sized
attack
some pawn storm potential efore before
inviting the the pin and wind while the
game 12 moves London refuted yeah the
the London is now just a closed opening
h5 to strong is that YouTube worthy
maybe it's YouTube worthy that'll be a
very short YouTube video
they each v London trap I don't think
I've I mean this was supposed to be
secret for a while but somehow the
secret has come out but yeah III is just
a blunder III e5 it's an incredible trap
and the bishops just it's just trapped I
think the best sign is to take f6 now
the bishop can move back and then like
can try like Bishop d3 at some points
maybe Bishop d3 here but I mean computer
will give like -1 minus 0.9 yeah not bad
after after 2 moves okay so for the
people watching in the future on YouTube
be aware h5 on YouTube it's venomous
I'll see you in the future